biden reinforces the false idea that
palestinians instigated this cycle of
violence
of course they instigated this cycle of
violence are you insane i cannot watch
that footage
and see a fair fight who's firing the
rockets what they are doing to the
palestinian people
is what they continue to do to our black
brothers and sisters here
they don't hate america because they
hate israel they hate israel because
they hate america
the left's willingness to cover for
actual honest-to-god terrorist groups is
astonishing to me it really is an
amazing thing
hamas makes no bones about the fact that
they wish to wipe out every
jew okay this is not a conflict over
land this is not a conflict
over borders this is not a you have one
group that wishes to kill everyone of a
particular group
and one group that wishes to live there
they are being very inconvenient and
that they are not willingly dying
there have been times in the past where
jews were quite soft in their own
defense it didn't end well for them
that's never going to happen again
that's why the state of israel exists
and people are angry that the state of
israel exists and so you have to come up
with all sorts of bizarre justifications
for why israel is not right
to defend itself here fortunately we
have congress people sitting congress
people
who are full on in on this sort of stuff
so for example you have alexander
ocasio-cortez openly defending hamas
right this genius so joe biden said that
israel has a right to defend itself
which by the way isn't it kind of
amazing that you have to actually say
that
israel which is a sovereign country has
the right to defend itself
what would the converse be it doesn't
have the right to defend itself of
course it has the right to defend itself
you know what happened if there were a
terrorist group or
say the government of mexico which is
actually what is going on hamas is the
government of the gaza strip
what if the government of mexico were
firing hundreds of rockets into san
diego
do you know how long that government
would last zero days we would be
planting the american flag in mexico
city immediately
okay this notion that israel is supposed
to sit around and bear this sort of
stuff is insane so biden says
israel has a right to defend itself
which is like the mildest form of okay
israel can kill a few hamas leaders
alexander ocasio-cortez then tweets out
blanket statements like these blanket
statements
what state doesn't have the right to
defend itself blanket statements like
these with little context or
acknowledgement of what precipitated the
cycle of violence
namely the expulsions of palestinians
and attacks on al-aqsa dehumanize
palestinians and imply the u.s will look
the other way at human rights violations
it's wrong
so it's wrong for her for the jewish
state to defend itself
he's saying that israel doesn't have a
right to defend itself from ongoing
consistent rocket attacks directed
at civilians okay that's
there's a point where being anti-israel
shifts over into being anti-semitic
okay and at the point where you're
saying that the jewish state doesn't
have the same rights as any other state
on planet earth
you have reached this point okay
alexander ocasio-cortez tweeted out by
only stepping in to name hamas's actions
which are condemnable and refusing to
acknowledge the rights of palestinians
biden reinforces the false idea that
palestinians instigated the cycle of
violence
of course they instigated this cycle of
violence are you insane
who's firing the rockets who started
the riots at al-aqsa okay that is a lie
to say that the israelis started the
riots in al-aqsa it is not
true it is an overt lie she says this is
not neutral language it takes a side the
side of occupation
she's an ignoramus and she's a fool okay
and that is perfectly clear
but so but you know i will attribute
to i'll attribute ignorance to her i
will attribute malice to rashida talib
so rashidali is just a malicious
pro-terror liar so here's rashida talib
at a rally yesterday
promoting the the leftist idea the
international leftist idea
that the subjugated of the world are all
in solidarity
with one another and that the true story
of humanity is
white people all over and she counts
jews with whites white people all over
who are subjugating
brown people all over this is something
that jamal bowman who's standing right
next to her she totally
when she says this also is putting out
there it's the reason why black lives
matter hasn't
has in its manifesto in its program and
the israeli occupation
and because there's a lie that is out
there going all the way back to franz
fanon that basically anybody
who has a european way of life is an
oppressor and anybody else
is not an oppressor they are the
victimized and so the oppresses of the
world have to rise up in
anti-colonialist fashion right that's
what this language is
so here's rashida talib suggesting that
what the
what the israelis are quote-unquote
doing to the palestinians is what the
police
do to black and brown people i assume
that's what she means by they because if
she doesn't mean the police
by they if she doesn't mean two separate
terms by they as you will see
then she's just talking about the jews
and that's just pure anti-semitism so
here's rashida talib suggesting somehow
a connection
between police treatment of black and
brown people in the united states which
again she lies about so israeli
treatment
of palestinians so there are a few
things that are wrong with this one
the police in the united states are not
systemically racist put that aside
number two the israelis are not white
okay this this bizarre notion that the
israelis are white ignores the fact
that like half of israelis more than
half of israelis by percentage
are from arabic countries the jews who
have been killed in israel
there's some from yemen there's some
from morocco there there
are plenty of jews who are not white
okay and jews technically speaking
we're not white until like the last five
minutes when they became prominent in
american politics until then they were
considered an out group okay but here's
where shita talib
pushing this vile nonsense this vile
racially polarizing nonsense
and by the way pro hamas nonsense
because she has narrow words to say
about hamas firing
rockets indiscriminately into civilian
population centers and using human
shields in order to protect themselves
our freedom is interconnected with black
brown
indigenous it is connected
what they are doing to the palestinian
people
is what they continue to do to our black
brothers and sisters here
to their
so i want you community know this if you
are marching for freedom of philosophy
please
know that you must be watching for
everybody's freedom
it is all interconnected it's all
interconnected you see
this is how you grow this movement but
by the way it is the truth for the left
you wonder you wonder about the red what
the people have termed the red green
alliance
meaning the sort of communist red red
islamist alliance the answer is they're
aimed at tearing down american
institutions tearing down western
institutions israel is seen as an
extension of that
they don't hate america because they
hate israel they hate israel because
they hate america
i mean this is the basic notion that
rashida talib
wants is connecting the institutions of
the united states with what's going on
in israel in order to conflate all of
that
you have to acknowledge that what she's
really attempting to do is condemn all
of the systems of the west
because there is some supposed
underclass that is being repressed by
these systems
and so she'll make excuses for any level
of violence in the same way that members
of the radical democratic party make
excuses for people burning down cities
and murdering people in the united
states they make excuses for hamas
firing rockets indiscriminately into
civilian areas
now again this is all anti-factual
sumiya santosh is a 32 year old
indian woman who in order to care for
her nine-year-old boy found work in
ashkelon caring for an eight-year-old
woman
and uh she was blown up by hamas like
yesterday
nineteen-year-old yehuda guetta from
libya
was shot and killed earlier this week by
a palestinian american
named montas shalaby who's motivated
according to his neighbors by equal
parts jew hatred and heavy gambling
deaths
that's according to tablet mag the the
basic
attempt to conflate american racial
politics with the middle east is
not only intellectually dishonest but
has terrible motivations
okay and this is by the way why you are
seeing jews getting beat up
in different places in the united states
yesterday in florida there was a truck
that was driving around
jewish rallies that saying hitler was
right okay the conflation between
anti-zionism and zionism and
anti-semitism
not everybody who doesn't like israel is
an anti-semite but every anti-semite is
anti-israel
okay so it's it's pretty it's pretty
incredible to see these narratives
trotted out that perhaps the dumbest
narrative of course
is the narrative trotted out by trevor
noah so yesterday trevor noah
literally said that israel should stop
defending itself because they're too
good at defending themselves
just personally i cannot watch that
footage and hear those numbers
and see a fair fight like set aside
motives and intentions
and just look at technology technology
alone
israel has one of the most powerful
militaries
in the world and i know that people are
going to hate me for this
but i just want to ask an honest
question here
if you are in a fight where the other
person
cannot beat you how hard should you
retaliate
when they try to hurt you um as hard as
you need to to make them stop hurting
you also by hurt you
i think that he is making a pretty
significant category error here
there's a difference between a child
trying to physically harm me
and a terrorist group firing rockets at
people and murdering them
the answer is as much as you need to do
to stop hamas's capacity to commit
terror attacks
but i guess i shouldn't be surprised
because the entire american left has
also decided that if a
black girl swings a knife at another
black girl the cop shouldn't shoot her
because of power imbalance or some such
nonsense none of this is shocking it's
just morally blind
and moral blindness is the name of the
game when it comes to the american and
international left
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wear are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe
ring that bell because you're not going
to want to miss a single moment